you made it you made it you made it oh
yeah you made it
it you made it weird with Pete
hes what's happening weirdos this is a a
very very exciting episode for me this
is Matt Johnson Katie our producer the
wonderful Katie LaVine for years has
been telling me about about Nirvana the
band the show uh which is a Canadian
television show that Matt co-created and
uh boy I wish I had listened to her
sooner it is my current Obsession I also
love the movie as you guys know
Blackberry which Matt uh directed and it
is
incredible and he is incredible and what
follows is a very inspiring and
interesting conversation about film
creativity in general inspiration Drive
I took a lot of notes from this episode
and it really sort of lit a fire under
me in terms of some of the things that
I'm trying to create so if you have some
Endeavor uh that you've been pursuing
and have been looking for some
motivation uh this is the episode for
you he's deeply funny deeply thoughtful
and so intelligent I'm so glad you guys
are here check out Blackberry check out
Nirvana the band the show and uh I'm so
glad you're here to check out this
episode only a couple things to play up
top it's all at P homes.com the 30th of
January I'll be at Largo largo-la
docomo that show in La once a month this
next one is going to be a big one I'm
very excited for it we also have a
couple shows on P homes.com we have
Chicago is up for sale we have a night
in Oxnard we have a night at the Irvine
Improv all in California and then we
have the Netflix is a joke Festival
which I'll be doing as well so check all
of those tour dates out it's a new hour
I'm very excited about it if you haven't
seen the old hour it's on Netflix right
now it's called I am not for everyone
please check that out and if you like
this show please try a pizza pick
meaning we only do ads for things that I
actually use and absolutely love like
our friends at Living Libations living
Libations is a high-end badass highly
effective natural skin care hair teeth
babies whatever ever your needs are in
the health and beauty department whether
it's uh skin care like I use their best
skin ever uh moisturizer at night I also
put it on during the day Val also uses
that and loves it we put uh love the sun
zinc based sunblock on Leela in the
sunny times of the year that is a huge
game Cher it's so hard to find an
actually natural alternative to the
chemical nightmares that they have out
there because obviously what we're
putting on our body gets in our body so
we should be careful to buy products
that are amazing living Libations and
have ingredients that we can easily
pronounce and recognize that is also
living Libations great way to support
the show get something small or do what
Val and I did which is a total medicine
cabinet Beauty cabinet bathroom overhaul
uh and replace all of those horrible
products that are filled with toxic
chemicals that were never intended for
humans 15% off go to living Libations
docomo the show support your body that's
living li.com weird it's also brought to
us from our friends at on it and alphab
brain you guys know this by now I'm
obsessed with alphab brain it is a new
atropic which means it helps with memory
focus and concentration every episode of
this podcast for the past all 700
episodes I've always always always taken
two or three Alpha Brain about 15
minutes before we started rolling also
anytime I'm doing standup anytime I'm
writing a script I really wish I had
known about it when I was in college or
taking tests I take it before I read
books just to retain more of it
basically anything you're doing that
involves your brain involves Focus
concentration and Memory Alpha Brain is
not a stimulant it's not like coffee
it's giving you Earth grown ingredients
to help you concentrate it is amazing
give it a try it's the best way to know
if you'll love it like I do go to onit n
nit.com weird and you will get 10% off
everything on that landing page that's
on
it.com weird all right everybody see you
out there on the road enjoy Matt Johnson
check out everything he's ever done he's
amazing you're about to see get into it
you're in uh Winnipeg right now
buddy that's where my family uh
immigrated to from Iceland Iceland to
Winnipeg well they're very similar
that's a huge Atlantic population in
Winnipeg where you are right now is that
real huge huge huge huge I'm not shocked
it is uh where are you you're in a
you're in oh Toronto I'm in an attic at
in our production house in Toronto I am
sorry I have to apologize before we
started recording I screamed at you and
I have to because you started talking I
said don't talk and I have to give you a
disclaimer I've been watching it's such
a pleasure to meet you I'm such a huge
fan of yours and in my defense I've been
watching I have a day off here and I've
been watching Nirvana the band the show
and what episode are you up to I'm on
season two episode three or four Mrs
Doubtfire have you have you watched the
Mrs Doubtfire episode no I'm I'm you
just got the Uber Eats order and you
answered the phone it's my it's my
favorite it's my favorite thing I've
ever done in my life that specific
episode is for me the best thing I
probably will ever do in my whole career
are you [__] me I wish I had
finished it I was literally I'll tell
you well I closed the window but I'm
like probably well that's like what
halfway in N yeah you you just you just
passed like Matt's Big dilemma which is
that Jay wants him to appear as both
Tony and Matt just like in the movie Mrs
Doubtfire where Robin Williams has to go
to this dinner both as himself and as
Mrs Doubtfire otherwise he's gonna lose
this big job and Matt has without
meaning to put himself in the exact same
situation of doing this plan at the rivy
where he needs to be both Matt and Tony
otherwise Jay will not be happy ah yeah
I won't ruin it I won't ruin it I'm
noticing that the that the light next to
me is is just behaving all kinds of
crazy so yeah I wouldn't yeah it it
looks great but to finish my apology you
I'm alone day off and all I've been
doing is watching that show other than
like a little fitting that I did so
that's the human interaction I've had
and really I want to give you a
compliment is that not only has it just
been delighting me like I'm alone in
this sort of not to say Winnipeg is sad
but you know it's kind of all about it
sort of locked in and my family left
this morning completely bare tree behind
you is telling a huge Story the
symbolism of it is gorgeous and there's
a convalescent home across the street
which is
actually I didn't know we still called
them convalescent homes but Winnipeg is
very on the nose it's a convalescent
home yeah um so here's what I'm trying
to say is that like first of all I I I
[__] love it um I got introduced to
you by Glenn Howton because I love
Blackberry it's [__] incredible we
can get to that but my producer Katie
was like you gotta watch that show so
I'm so glad I am watching it and even
after we chat I'm gonna keep watching it
which is the only true compliment right
I couldn't agree more right couldn't
agree more it's not research I'm [__]
dying
laughing loving everything about it um
but here here's the apology is it got my
silly beans from zero to a 100 so you're
talking to a guy who's been watching you
only be M character so I'm like oh I'll
just go in at 10 so I need to check
myself after I've wrecked myself but
that's why I screamed at you you know
funny believe it or not I'm sure you
deal with this in your life all the time
because I think you and I are Kindred
Spirits in a way I I oddly think we
almost look like family
like so there we have a similar I don't
know what it is it's the VIS if you saw
us at a distance you'd be like ah like
we should we could play Brothers in a
film and I think it would be a great
movie I agree you probably um I I don't
to use the word suffer but you probably
have the same uh dilemma that I often
have in public which is that I'm not
sure what you're like uh as an
individual but I'm a little bit uh
introverted and and kind of quiet and
when people meet me in real life and
they only know me from my work I always
find them their eyes kind of sink as
they realize it's almost like they're
meeting my twin brother do you know what
I mean like you can't be him
like whatever you are is not what I like
I am thrilled and buddy that's what just
happened to you and I even sort of gave
myself the note like don't do that
because you're right that does happen to
me because of the Batman videos and
stuff people come up to me they say
assmouth vag and I'm like I'm with my
daughter or whatever you know know but
like I am you saw me raise my hand I'm
deeply
introverted um I I'd like to ask
you what what's your response I feel
like like I'm a cat who learned how to
do an impression of a dog and when I
watch you on Nirvana the band the show
you're sort of I think why where you're
getting Kindred Spirits is you're doing
what I
do meaning I think the funniest thing I
do is like let it off the leash and sort
of go nuts you know what I mean big and
wild and then when I'm private I go back
into cat but I do a pretty good dog and
that is an aspect of me but I feel more
like a like usually with a day off like
today I I'm like rubbing my hands
together like a like a delicious meal
and I can't wait to be quiet and kind of
alone yeah alone and recharge you
recharge like that tell me what that
made you think I was gonna well let mean
look at where I am this is where I spend
most of my time in a gigantic empty
Attic by myself so you didn't clean this
up for the shot
no it's just sparse yeah well mean this
is like like an office at the same time
but this is it's great you get to be
quiet it's wonderful what I was going to
say is that um what I see in a lot of
your performance is a which is what I
see in a lot of the best comedians is a
return
to a kind of uh innocent childhood like
the way a child would approach things
the way a child would see things yes and
then and then doing that through it's
why I love um uh uh movies or television
where where and it's why I this myself
where it's like an adult man but who's
seeing things with the optimism and the
naivity of a boy who knows nothing and
doesn't understand consequences and I
think that I'm I'm very good at tapping
into that but then in real life I'm so
the exact opposite in
Blackberry uh this this anecdote is
haunting me which is that everybody who
doesn't know me who sees me H in public
is like oh my gosh you're exactly like
the character you play it's crazy I
can't believe how much in real life you
are like this guy and and then all my
friends the people who've known me since
I was a kid who would see me and talk
about the film and be like oh my God
Matt I can't believe how much you're
like Jim I can't believe how much you
are like the character that Glenn plays
and so that w wow I that's brilliant I
relate to his I sort of have to repress
but Delight in Glenn's character who's
like a hotthead almost like a a bill bur
type I'm drawn to those guys that are
just like shut the [__] up shut the F
like when he goes when he's on the call
about the modems and he goes and he
hangs up I get like the biggest movie
boner for moments like that where I'm
like that energy is so essential to
getting things done and I and I have
that I have this like and I know you
have that as a filmmaker it's like just
[__] do it just [__] do it run on
the subway run on the sub or whatever it
yes exactly exactly exactly people who
don't know what I mean you you you were
talking about you go for forgiveness
over permission you ran on the subway I
was watching I also watched some it's
very hard to find Matt so I couldn't
find season one and I ended up watching
some fan-made best of stuff so I saw
some and interviews with you and when I
watched the clip of you guys running
through the subway I was
legit like afraid I like that you would
touch the Third real and and I I just to
kind of load you I saw you talking about
like yeah things that haven't been done
before haven't been done for a reason
and if you could marry that into
forgiveness permission just I think
filmmakers would love to hear you talk a
little about that yeah well in some ways
that became my sort of deao philosophy
behind making anything which is that
when I was in film
school because I went to a Canadian film
school and because Canada generally I
mean you're in Winnipeg right now so
maybe you're feeling this a little bit
is a very risk averse country and we're
in a very risk-averse system which in
some
ways it's it's the opposite of America
Blackberry that movie is a little bit
about this tension as well where it's
very rare in Canada for people to just
say [__] it and do things for them to be
like I'm gonna do this and I and and and
damn the consequences and because of
that we have a very strict set of
imposed and implied tacit rules that
that people play Within and in film
school I really felt this I really felt
like a like simple things like you can't
you always need to have a very strict
script before you shoot anything you
can't shoot anything in public you can't
shoot anything with real people can't
film with animals can't fil film with
children like things that are almost if
you're in the film business like you
hear these things as maxims but I
thought of all these things as oh I'm
gonna try to do work that is only doing
those things simply because nobody else
is doing them and so if I get lucky and
it works then I'll be the only person
this is me thinking as like a
20-year-old kid right I'll be the only
person who has done it and I think for
any young people who is trying to do
anything not just film as I've matured
I've realize this is a decent Philosophy
for for most practices is that the
things that are not allowed or the
things that are even slightly verboten
if you flip any set of rules over
there's a map on the other side and that
map is towards gold that nobody has
gotten to because everybody stops at the
rules and is like okay yeah well we
can't do that yeah um it it also with
things like copyright infringement or
fair use like even getting granular
around like what legally you can and
can't do I find that there's a there's a
path forward where it's like oh nobody
knows how to do this because they all
think they'll get in trouble if they do
right it's just and it's free and it's
free yeah but those become the markers
like if I I also saw you like if it's
uncomfortable that's a good Touchstone
of like we're into something novel it
seems like the most obvious thing in the
world people aren't doing it so you
should you should do that it also brings
to mind like like I think it was
chaplain not Buster Keaton with the
house maybe it was Buster Keaton the
house that's buer ke that's Buster
Keaton yeah the Buster Keaton shot it's
a famous shot where the house Falls and
you know they had to do it to the
millimeter so it wouldn't kill him it
reminds me of that and there there's
almost something silent filmy about your
look too as Matt in Nirvana the suit and
the hat it's is that any sort of a a
reference for you Vaudeville big time
like I like I that's almost like an uh
like the
anacronismo in the 90s but with the
aesthetic and mindset of uh yeah silent
era Cinema um yes but but again I was so
young when I was putting that together
that all these things were happening
subconsciously it's not like I was
thinking oh these are Vaudeville guys
and this is
this is how they behave it was it was
really just like kind of getting lucky
and then iterating on it when you
consume and when your life just is about
certain stuff you don't have to make an
effort to infuse those things into your
work so I think that's one of the big
secrets of of almost any art discipline
as well is to try to watch and do as
much as you can the worst thing you can
do is just like nothing like like like
like playing the same video games or
watching the same movies over and over
and over again because you don't realize
that you're going to especially when
you're young Because by the time you're
old I'm not sure if you feel this way at
all like you get to a certain age I had
a teacher named uh Max Leighton who told
me in high school who is like well I'm
at the age where I feel as though I've
read enough and I've watched enough and
I don't really need to watch anymore and
I feel like like
that the older I got the less interest
in watching new movies I became the less
interested in in uh reading new books
that became it it was like a real effort
for me to to consume new stuff and so
much my personality is based on these
Touchstone things from the 90s and I was
happening by accident but but I'm kind
of stuck with these references like I'm
stuck with them in a way so are you
saying you don't really watch new stuff
I don't watch new stuff as much as I did
not even close not even close I was like
a voracious file when I was younger I
watched literally everything and now
it's It's a cruel irony that you wind up
like working so much or working on your
own stuff so much that you just don't it
seems like such a crazy Indulgence to
like go to a movie theater and watch new
movies or even to watch links of movies
you're like oh God wouldn't it be great
if I could if I if I could do that but
that might may just be me I don't know
you know I've always been of the Mind as
a standup and as you know a Creator in
different ways that if I like it meaning
my audience is growing in the same way
meaning I love I love Blackberry
Blackberry is not like um Iron Man I
Iron Man's a great movie I'm not I'm not
trying to poo modern not that's not even
modern but you know what I mean Avengers
endgame but like it reminds me of what I
think it's modern in certain ways but
it's also feels like a movie to me does
that make sense like it it feels like
how movies
that I remember feel so there's if I
like it there's an audience for it does
that make sense yeah of course well yeah
just basically following your own
instincts to the point where you feel
like you must be right because you like
it that's something I'm guilty of every
single day yeah the worst is when you've
got an idea and it's like you're in a
pitch room or something like that you're
working with your team and you're like I
can't it's like the the Supreme Court's
definition of pornography you know you
can't explain it but you know it when
you see it it's like you just know that
something is good and you can't explain
why it's good yeah that's a tough one
did you as a standup comedian I guess
you don't have to worry about that well
you get the feedback it's funny you
could you could think of standup as a
pitch meeting every show but I I kind of
like to soften that and think of it as
we're we're co-creating it with the
audience and I'm assuming you have that
with screenings and stuff that that
moment absolutely you can feel them
glazing over or or they're just not
responding like you thought they would
is that you know instantly it's it's
crazy one of the one of the the Great
Tricks about test screenings is that
often times you hold them hoping to get
feedback and people will give you what
they think afterwards if you sit in a
screening you don't need any feedback at
all yeah you know everything feel the
frequeny you you read everybody's mind
as it's happening and and I
uh I think screenings are very important
because you can do so few of them and
have them still seem fresh but it's like
that's another one of the free tools RS
that filmmakers have like it's funny how
similar that is to standup comedy where
you just you just know instantly Minds
you the difference is you're not
actually standing there I when I was
quite young I tried doing standup comedy
and this is when I was in my really
arrogant young man phase and I was 16 or
17 years old and I flew to San Francisco
to do open mic shows there because I was
too shy to do them in Toronto and it was
so painful so pain
one most painful things I've ever
experienced in my life did you where did
you go up was it at the clubs or was it
bars yeah yeah where any every every
place that had an open mic I just went
to every single one I was there for a
week and every single day I did like two
or three of them wow and it didn't bite
you yeah no I would say that's literally
what it did it like bit me so hard I
wanted to die oh I I mean like the bug
like it didn't I knew what you meant I
knew what no it was the opposite it was
the opposite in fact I was like oh I'm
gonna love this this is gonna be so
great and I didn't realize how much of
it was your ability to withstand failure
live and it seems as though every
comedian who's made it has withstood
whether they've known it or not so much
failure that then by the end of it you
wind up with only the best stuff it's
like you're editing a movie but the
movie's you yeah but then there's
casualties to that when
watching anything that you've made that
I've seen what I like about television
and film is that you can you have a
little bit more Authority in a sense
like I used to say on stage one of my
save lines was I I'd do a joke it
wouldn't work and I'd go I really Envy
like people in a play and and if you say
something and it's not funny they give
you the benefit of the doubt they're
like oh maybe that's like a theme or
maybe that maybe he's trying to be
dramatic but like every line has to work
and and what I love
about like okay so I was just watching
Nirvana uh the band on the show so I'll
stick to that it's like you get to kind
of introduce them to a different
vocabulary meaning like this is the way
this show is funny and you you almost
have to catch up to it so when I watch
the
utilitarian sort of pragmatic nature of
standup it can kill some really really
hilarious and interesting things because
you just want to get the laugh a laugh
yes and it sort of neuters a lot of
really a lot of like some of the most
brilliant people I saw in the first 10
years of standup aren't doing it anymore
and I don't say that to say they failed
or anything I'm saying that to say like
the the grind of it failed them the the
process of it failed them well do you
know about this uh biological um
evolutionary biological concept called
low adaptive Peak it's a really
interesting idea do you ski have you
ever been skiing before I can't ski
downhill skiing I I
okay the metaphor will work okay so a
low adaptive Peak is a concept in
biology where a species um figures out
how to survive some environmental
problem but with the lowest possible
adaptive sophisticated um uh tool so in
downhill skiing it would be like when
people snowplow and they ski like that
well that will get you down the hill but
it's not ideal skiing right but you can
stop there because you're like okay
great I learned how to get down the hill
perfect and so this is how you ski for
the rest of your life and with standup
comedy there's this kind of like okay I
gotta get a joke how can I get a joke
how can I get a laugh I Gotta Laugh like
this and because of that you wind up
stuck in this place where you never need
to go beyond it because getting the
laugh the easy way like left you there I
was finding that was happening to with
me when I was young with the first
iteration of Nirvana the band the show
which is that I found the things that
were working best were me just acting
completely screw loose like as offensive
as possible like so much less
sophisticated than than not to say the
show's that sophisticated but than than
it was when I got to do it again and and
I learned about that concept and I I was
like okay I can't fall into this trap
with myself which is that is that if you
can get some level of success by doing
the minimum amount of work yeah it's
almost like I learned this as well about
lying I was an inveterate liar my whole
life and was it was granting me great
success right because that's what lies
do like you avoid um consequences by
lying or you inflate your own selfworth
because you can fool people and I
trained myself unwillingly to become
such a great liar that I could have
great consequences for myself with no
work and then what I was left with in my
20s was the ability to lie extremely
well and no work ethic and no AB ability
to to do the things that I needed to do
so I had screwed myself in an almost
luciferian way right I had I it's like I
it's like i' made a wish on a monkey paw
to be well-liked and successful and I
got it but it was only through lies and
that's another thing that that uh that
was another example of this low adaptive
Peak that had no you're you're hearing
me exactly I'd love to hear a little bit
more about the lying when did that start
when I was a very young kid it was it
was an interesting process and that was
that now I I look back on it and think
differently but in my family I was very
close with my brother and uh and he and
my mom had a
interesting like Quirk which is that
they would all and I'm talking about
when I'm young young five or six years
old they would always ask me questions
that I knew they knew the answers
to you have you ever do you ever
witnessed this like somebody they ask
you okay great that's perfect because
because for me I haven't experienced
much in my adult life but it would be
things like oh were you just on the
phone with your friend Stephen knowing
full like I'm five years old I've got
one friend when am I on the phone right
so I knew that they knew the answer but
because I'd always be getting asked
these questions where I knew the asker
knew what the answer was I started to
lie to say that what they thought
reality was wasn't to put us in a kind
of like game where they would know I'd
lied but they couldn't admit that they
knew what the answer was because then
they'd be admitting that they didn't
need to ask the question and anyway I
played that game I played that game
maybe 50 times a day every day from age
five to
age
17 I you're really yeah keep going you
well I'm just saying and so by the end
of it by the time I'm going to
University into film school I had gotten
so good at lying with a straight face
about the most insane thing things and
i' also learned to tell lies in a way
where I could get it right to the point
where I knew somebody would believe me
even if I was saying something
completely insane and when you're
watching Nana the band the show most of
what you're watching is me using this in
public with real people right right
telling people my band is nirvana the
band I'm going to play a show at the
rivy I need your help and they all are
like yes we'll help you because you seem
sincere right uh I there you know
obviously lying is a frown upon social
uh
thing I have I have I have deep thoughts
on lies I think I think that lies really
are bad and that and that i' I've I've
I've learned to draw a distinction
between lying and storytelling because
all stories are lies but stories are
also true right so I think that there's
a difference between what's it in
service of yes exactly exactly yeah no
I'm with you but you're also bringing
back all these memories I remember being
a kid and wondering why my parents
didn't lie to me more like just silly
stuff like it's rare that I can say
something on this podcast that I don't
think I've said before but I remember
thinking as a kid that when I have a kid
I'm gonna pop my head in their bedroom
and say hey your friend Miguel called he
said dead
yeah yeah he said something
absurd that that there would be some imp
and like I knew that they would know
that I was lying but what I'm hearing
underneath this is something that comedy
is and and just sort of I don't know
what else to say other than like people
that are interested in what we call
reality and lying is a little bit of a
sonar ping going like are we really
doing this like what what is this like
it is sort of an absurd construct and a
lie like a joke a joke joke is a lie too
like like I'm shooting this movie and
and constantly people are like the
director wants you to wear gloves and
I'll always be like no like because I
just think that's funny you're flirting
it's a it's a flirt with like can we
stop
pretending that there's a director and
there's a movie it look I might be
unpacking it or flattering myself but
I'm like we're in outer space we're in
these time traveling Meats suits that
expire and everyone's walking around
going like I'm number three on the call
sheet and I'm like that's a joke and
like making these little Jokes which are
kind of like little lies is a way of um
not raging Against the Machine but just
kind of being like would you stop it
right can we stop pretending like this
is so serious and so concrete when it's
really just like a agreed upon web of of
[__] you know like hello Matthew I
see how are you today you know the dance
of it it's almost a little asurgery or
autistic whatever we're supposed to say
like this like what is everyone doing
and when I see someone like you
disrupting that it makes me feel a
little less alone does that make sense
oh absolutely I want let me let me
psychoanalyze that that what you bring
up for a second because I do that exact
same thing and I wonder if if if we're
doing it for the same reason so the
who's asking you to put on the gloves
we'll say it's the ad or somebody from
the Wardrobe Department okay so they
came up to you and say the director
wants to know if you'd put on these
gloves
well if if because I do the same thing
right if I get asked to do something by
a director or somebody it what when I'm
like when I say I'm you and I say no I'm
not going to do it and clearly it's a
joke what I'm doing is I'm saying look
why are you playing this game with me
where you're saying the director has
asked if I will put on the gloves as if
I have any choice what are you doing
why are you telling why are you being so
polite to me and saying Pete the
director has just wondered if you might
want to put on these gloves and it has
to do with these P the power hierarchy
within it this person speaking for the
director and it's just so nauseating to
watch that you just have no choice but
to act like as you say like in a kind of
Rage Against the Machine way say no I
won't because that of course in the same
way that me lying to my mom disrupts the
whole thing yeah because they know you
can't say no well it's a TR can't say
know it's a what I what I'm raging
against is a trance where we're like
sleepwalking through a process and then
before you know it your life is over you
know what I mean you never you never
went like stop it stop so I'd like to
have as many little NOS that you know
I'm Jo I'll say no while I'm putting on
the it's not even it doesn't even slow
the day that almost makes it better that
almost makes it better it's a funnier
bit to put them on No No's no way I'm
wearing these I love and you mentioned
power and Status which which are themes
that I see in your work making fun of
being cool making fun of being important
making fun of being successful and we
can unpack that but like whoever the the
number one on on the number one is the
star of the movie I like making fun of
them the most maybe the director and the
and the star the most because you're not
supposed to like exactly on the first
day and and she was joking she was like
number one on the call sheet and I went
number two in our pants and and like
just like I can't it will not stand and
and she died laughing but like I feel
like that's the gift of comedy and and
one of the greatest achievements if not
the greatest achievement of my life and
I saw my dad wishing he could uh or you
know kind of acting like he does have
this mantle to be honest but when you
are a comedian and we when people
understand that you're a comedian it's
it's understood that you're gonna say
and do and behave all the ways you're
not supposed to say do and behave
because he's just joking that that's
it's like a little badge that you get to
wear well you must mock the king that's
it you must mock the king otherwise what
what are you doing it's one of the great
privileges is that for some reason
Society honors people who are speaking a
kind of
devilish not to invoke uh religion again
but almost like like satanic truths in a
way and I mean that positively right not
like not like not like Satan is in like
the depth of all evil but I mean like
true satanic truths where it's like oh
is it like that's almost true but it's
not true enough that we can get them in
trouble like those yeah they're so
delicious and fun it is it's like what
what we're talking about is ways to make
life a little bit more interesting and I
know you were doing that as a child with
lies I was craving that my parents would
do it more with me because just going
back to my
point I don't want to sleepwalk through
life you know I and I see you in the
show that you made it's like I don't
want to just make another another
[__] show and I saw you in an
interview talking about
doing good work but one of the things
that I think is so interesting is that
we will settle to do not good work when
really I think deep down everyone would
like to do good work but that's another
type of sleepwalking like we'll just I
mean I'm never going to forget your
metaphor we'll just go down the mountain
Snow Play
because it's easy right because and
we'll get down and we will get down the
mountain and that's and that's a big
problem again this is sort of
nationalistic but that's a big problem
with my country with Canada versus the
US is that there just is not there's
basically no appetite to be great which
is sort of an odd thing to say but it's
a it's a national Pro problem that that
I mean I put it in the movie literally
that this that this there's this good
enough philosophy behind everything
everybody does is like Ah that's good
enough that's good enough yeah good
enough is the enemy of of humanity of
humanity I love which I deeply believe
right because if if you if you're like
ah this is good enough like we it can be
released like this
well H the real problem is that like
especially with art in only in order to
get to like like that second level of
like oh wow I'm really proud of this
Bears a massive personal cost on you
because nobody's going to have the
aesthetic standards that you do about
your own work nobody's going to be like
you know this really could be better
it's not releasable in fact it's the
opposite everybody on your team wants
you to be finished more than anything
like can it just be finished please and
you need to be the one who's like yeah
it would be so easy for me to say yes
this is done because then we'd be done
yeah we could all get paid wouldn't that
be great right but it's not done
because yeah I heard you say that you
were like well that'll require a
re-shoot I I heard you say in an
interview and you're like then we'll do
a re-shoot and like yeah no one has that
attitude like that I've seen it's just
people get really hung up on how
difficult it would be to do something
and what a headache it would be to do
something and I you know it's just just
get down the mountain and just get paid
oh yeah just get paid is a huge huge
problem it's
ating right and look I I've I've
succumbed to it more than once so I I
understand that I'm thinking you know
what else came to mind when you're
talking about you can get down the
mountain just snowplowing there's also
something in nature like a bubble is
just like the most energy efficient way
yeah for like I can't use the physics
but like for a structure to take a shape
so it takes the shape everything is
about energy conservation right it's
like oh and there's another way to put
that it's like we'll go to so much
greater lengths than we will to then
we'll go to such greater lengths to
avoid pain then we will to gain pleasure
that one that one changed my life when I
heard that I was like oh my God I'm I do
that everybody does I I do it all the
time especially in terms of being in
public and being humiliated like
humiliation is one of the most like
you're desperate to avoid it in fact
combining that with this concept of
Comedy it's like oh I'll do anything I
can do to get a laugh at this moment
I'll do absolutely anything yeah it's
why I I found that after that
humiliation as a young person trying to
be a stand-up comic I realized oh I need
to find
a like a way of working where I can
humiliate myself over and over again
knowing full well that I will control
the end result and so when you're
watching Deana the band the show or when
you're watching Blackberry it's like
you're not seeing the hundreds of hours
of stuff that is completely awful awful
awful like the terrible stuff that is is
so bad and it's why I love working with
actors because I I afford them that same
gift one of the early things I said to
Glenn was it was the deal that we made
early on I was like look if you never
ever ever try to be funny ever I promise
I can make you the funniest person in
this movie and I and I I I guarantee it
if you just never be funny and you feel
like you're not being funny and and one
of his big concerns I'm not sure if he
talked to you about this was I'm not
funny he saw the movie he saw the movie
and thought he wasn't funny which is so
amazing right like what what a
success this was that he he did it so
hard that he saw himself he's like I'm a
I'm a hatable awful character I hate
what I've done and I was like trust me
trust me people are gonna be blown away
but that's that's great Direction
because I've noticed you know what it is
when I'm in a scene and you know we're
just shooting yesterday and I catch
myself when my coverage is is head-on
I'm just favoring head on a little bit
more you know what I mean and that's
that's a dangerous instinct is because
you it's so the ego is such a tricky
thing and you want to score and what I
hear Glenn saying is something I've felt
before too which is like uh even though
I want people to like my performance
really what I still want above all is
for people to think that I'm like a good
guy and like a nice guy and like we
should we give him resources give him
romantic Partners give give him food you
know like so it's such a so you cut him
did he ever did you ever feel like he
was being funny and you were like well
we're not going to use
that uh he was good to his word believe
it or not I never I I can't think of
even one time in between takes I was
like are you trying to be funny but
that's because we had a early on we knew
what we wanted he and I were like really
like in lock step trying to do this
thing together and it was that promise
that if he if he never was funny that I
that we could do something really
amazing and I think he just he bought it
now after the movie was done and he
foresaw it I think he was quite upset
but but then we premiered and he and he
and he was happy again so oh well that
oh what an incredible story so talking a
little bit about Canada and and their
lack what how did you phrase it there's
no desire to be great I well I think
it's it's it's a deep lack is that that
we as a as a country it comes from a
risk aversion I I'm telling you this is
our biggest problem here here's the big
problem in Canada you can't get fired
for failing at any of like the like like
you know how studio is exact if exacts
if they release a bad movie they're
fired if they green light something
that's too expensive and it bombs
they're fired that that's that does it's
impossible in this can't happen yeah it
cannot happen yeah wow it's like the
office should have happened in Canada
because remember people were like why
doesn't Michael Scott get fired if it
was in Canada everyone would have been
like it would make perfect sense
actually it's one of the reasons that
shows such a huge hit here and they have
a very Canadian affectation in the
office oh yeah definitely definitely
like that's just the way things work if
you work in government and the problem
is like movies in Canada is an arm of
the government wow yeah I I saw you
explain that somewhere else too where
it's like they're funded by something
that's essentially a government uh it
just is it's not even essentially a
government arm it literally is an arm of
the government wow yeah that's crazy
okay so to talk a little bit about again
I I like all good comedy I do think
you're skewering ego and and success and
I think I love Corporation movies like
like blackberry and I do think they
touch on what's wrong with the American
meaning North America what do I say you
just say American Canada is well that's
North American but if I were to say
American I'd be talking about your
country yeah yeah I'm okay America um
don't point at me when you say your
country
look between the two of
us but like I love those stories because
they
seem they don't just seem they are
perfect metaphors for a life that's that
goes sideways they're like they're these
hero Journeys where it's like they start
in the garage or the basement or or you
know and they're all friends and then
success comes their way and then you
know you see this with Jay's character
the founder of
blackberry like then they start wanting
to succeed for success's sake like or
they don't want to lose what they got
that's another big problem yeah that's
another big problem nobody knows what to
do when you've already won I see this in
Show Business I see a lot of very
dissatisfied multi-millionaire famous
people that just there's no Playbook
they they they rang the bell and and
blackberry rang the bell was like the
number number one phone huge phone right
they couldn't get any bigger exactly and
now it's completely gone do you do you
see what I'm getting at is the idea that
these you're talking about the business
movie as the microcosm of like a life
gone wrong or a life well live yes yes
well it's it's funny you you you brought
up the idea of like like young men in a
garage and the kind of
fraternalism at all this is one of my
favorites so this is this is one of the
this one of the original original like
like pre-biblical myths and
um it has a whole beginning where him
and his best friend fight and the one
guy dies but the part of it that I love
is the second half of it okay so King
Gilgamesh is like the ruler of this
great Kingdom and it's like it's amazing
he's he's a ostensibly a billionaire but
he's like ah but my best friend just
died I don't want to die I need to find
a way to conquer death I want to live
forever so he leaves his kingdom which
he hates he's grown so tired of it he's
like my kingdom is look at this opulence
boredom everybody just bows to me I hate
it here I'm leaving so he goes off into
the Wilderness to try to meet the Gods
in order to barter for eternal life and
all of these people he meets they give
him little tests and they're like okay
if you can do this then we'll let you
live forever if you can swim to the
bottom of this ocean and find this roote
you can live forever and he fails all of
them one of them is you have to stay
awake for five days or something and he
like falls asleep after one like he just
can't win everything Gilgamesh does he
can't he can't do it even though he
wants this so badly and after enough of
these trials he's like [__] it I can't I
failed and he goes home walks through
the desert back to his kingdom and he's
just like I [__] suck God damn it and
he gets back to his kingdom and as he
sees it cresting over the horizon and he
sees it in all its Glory he just starts
to cry and he's like this place looks
great what a beautiful kingdom I've
returned to I love it here and he
re-enters and is so stoked it's like he
has somehow revivified himself through
the p through the power of failure by
losing and failing and trying to do
something now he's feeling like ah I can
now live in this place I can live in
this Kingdom again and that's like uh
It's a Wonderful Life almost yeah well
right well look this story's been ripped
off a million times Nirvana the band is
a ripoff of the myth of bgesh blackberry
I was trying to do kind of like uh
like the beginnings of that but then
gone completely wrong where they didn't
see the wisdom of it like it's no it's
no um mistake that at the end of the
movie Mike is doing the exact same thing
that he did at the beginning of the
movie and trying to fix this tiny little
physical problem that he was at the
beginning of the film trying to fix and
anyway all this is to say that I think
one of the reasons that these stories of
Corporations and corporate hierarchies
and beginnings of like very small groups
that then go on to change the world but
then wind up in a in a state of personal
failure are are
so I don't know they're so ubiquitous
but also so powerful is because they're
tapping in to these ancient myths
without telling us that they're doing
that and and I think that whatever movie
you pick that is that is effective and
and is is using the same kind of story
beat uh progression is actually secretly
telling you a Mythic story and you just
don't realize it do you know bork the
musician bork I mean obviously yeah she
she's got a great quote about art
because she was asked what what the job
of an artist is and she said the job of
an artist is to connect the myths of
your ancestors with the future and
that's all that an artist does and uh
and I I took that really seriously so so
anyway yeah in in in Blackberry it's
like I'm trying to work all these things
out um but they don't
Lon well look you could argue that Jim
definitely does because Jim is so
miserable like you don't see him smile
at some purpose Glenn and I had this
game where it's like no matter what just
don't smile and he never does except for
when you know his enemies are suffering
um and uh and and the only and because
he's never at peace he's never gotten
over the humiliation of being fired at
the beginning of the film and so he's
doing everything he can just just like
Gilgamesh right he saw he his death at
the beginning of the film I could die if
I have a boss that can fire me I could
die and so he goes out into the world
and he says I am never going to die and
so he's willing to do anything to create
so much of a buffer between him and
failure that no matter what happens he's
going to be the richest guy he's gonna
like if if Mike needs these Engineers
he'll go get them he does all of these
things and in the end he's betrayed like
Caesar by the guy that he himself
created right he gets stabbed in the
back by his partner and rather than
being like oh [__] like you expect this
guy who's been screaming all movie to
now rip the head off of this loser but
instead he thinks about it then Smiles
in the same way that Gilgamesh did when
he saw his kingdom at the end after all
this failure because he's like ah I'm
home like there's a real quote that I
heard after the movie came out from Jim
Balley Jim didn't tell me the story one
of his best friends did and it was after
all this happened to Jim the SEC came
for him he lost everything right he went
to lunch with a friend and the friend
was sitting there and watched Jim come
in and Jim was the kind of guy who would
never meet with anybody for more than 15
minutes because he was so like I gotta
go Gotta Go he was always working and he
sat down he had lunch with this guy for
two hours and the guy said Jim I got to
say like I've never seen you like this
before you seem happy I'm worried you're
going to commit suicide like are you out
of your mind like why are you in such a
good mood and he said you
know it took me losing everything to
realize what a big shot I was and and so
he could finally feel like oh wow I
actually am great and I only could feel
it because I lost everything and yeah I
didn't know that before we made the film
but but it was it was uh fun to hear
because it meant that we getting at
something did Jim bowsley so he's the
guy that if if you haven't seen
Blackberry he's he's Glenn Harton's
character he's sort of the hard-headed
guy who takes these young squabs with a
vision and and drives him into success
and then in the end he sort of is
betrayed did he lose all his money like
it seems no he didn't lose all of his
money he just he just lost uh huge am a
huge amount of money and he was for lack
of a better word fired from from
Blackberry he was forced so his biggest
fear so he did die it's yeah no the
these themes are I mean this maybe I'm
flattering myself again but like the
movie is deeply resonant with me and as
you're explaining this I think these
borky themes really she's she's true
she's right when Bor said that I was
like holy [__] Bor yeah you're a genius
like yes exactly and as soon as you
realize that as soon as you realize oh
the only thing we're supposed to be
doing is basically
like like revivifying these old stories
with new skin because that's kind of
what made us who we are it makes it
makes not only life like way more
enjoyable because you feel like you're
kind of you're like animating the
tongues of old gods but it means that
you know you have purpose behind
everything you do because you're like oh
you wait in the same way that you said
like you wait until you see something
that you're interested in you find an
interest and you follow it and then you
you go deep enough in it to realize how
it's connected to stories that were
making people animated you know 10,000
years ago and now you feel at home on
the planet
right exactly Richard roor this um
Franciscan that I love he says
essentially Christianity is um studying
how to lose well how to lose yeah right
well look that's the passion that's the
story of passion lose lose everything he
goes look at the it's right in front of
your face he goes look at the the the
[__] the logo for lack of a better
term of the religion is a guy dying
dying yeah and we all gather and watch
that and look at it but like the most
obvious things it's staring you right in
the face but it's hidden in plain sight
we think or I I'll say I thought that
Christianity was about having a genie
that would Grant your wishes and but I'm
like but this Genie didn't even save his
own son right yeah right exactly looking
at it traditionally and that's then you
know through years of study my
perception of that story changed was was
was Jesus Jesus was dying and not losing
his higher identity you know what I mean
not losing some sense of being Spirit or
whatever you want to say meaning
Gilgamesh didn't really do it well we
can talk about whether or not you
thought he did it but you know these
stories where you go you try to cheat
death you bargain with the gods you
can't do it and then you still find an
equinity in your inevitable place as a
loser as someone who can't hold on to
anything it also really reminds me of
the story of the Buddha of of sedara who
was also a king in a kingdom who was
also bored with the origin leaves
realizes he's gonna die and then
seeks his his bargaining with the gods
is somewhat different he he looked for
uh surrender or or however else you want
to phrase that but the but these themes
are are there and they need to be told
and they need to be told over and over
and over again and and to to be
constantly updated because it's in the
it's like the further away we get from
them the more out of place or like well
it's it's why I watch so many movies and
I'm like I don't know this is just
ridiculous I don't even know what this
is about it's like they're refusing to
to commit or to connect with with any
kind of old mythology yeah um yeah
you're talking about this you reminded
me of one of my favorite uh uh quotes
from a saint uh St Augustine who said um
Lord Make Me chased but not
yet one one one of the greats one of the
greats I think it was St Augustine 2
that said do what you want do whatever
you want and love God or love God and do
whatever you want which was so confusing
to me growing up because religion to me
was all about um adherence adherence was
about being polite being nice all the
same things I'm trying to do now that's
still in there as I'm trying to seem
like a nice and good guy and there's
nothing wrong with that
but now I'm like these epics and these
these great stories that survive I don't
think they're just calling us to like
get along and like be a functioning
person I think they're calling you to be
able to be crucified or betrayed or lose
everything and still know that you can't
not be at home that that's how I would
phrase it you can't not connected even
even more so to put yourself in the POS
position to be destroyed which is even
more of a of a challenge not just that
oh I know I could I'm resilient enough
that I could take being destroyed it's
that oh no I'm gonna go out to
intentionally be destroyed wow that's
yeah which is which is much scarier
right I would say we live in a
especially in my country in in a in a
place of pure safetyism where the idea
of putting yourself in a position where
you could suffer anything at all even a
bit is anathema like nobody's doing that
nobody's doing that which is so funny
because to me visiting here I admire the
grit with the cold you think the cold
would would produce more of a I can do
anything spirit it's more of a we've had
enough or yeah it sort of would you say
it sort of breaks people I mean it's
[__] intense yeah well where you are
specifically it's one of the coldest
places that is still habitable in the
country so yeah and it lends itself to a
lot of like I don't need a like big
bowls of pasta but as soon as I got here
I was like just give me hibernation food
and keep me inside and do you think that
sort of spread do you think that had
something to do with it yeah there's
certainly a northern hardiness that
where you're like where you're like I
just want to be safe because again the
elements are so vicious up here they're
so vicious and brutal I love them I love
them love what the cold I love the cold
and the snow yeah no I get that why why
is there so much incredible comedy that
comes from here is it because you're
such an outlier if you do want to shake
things up does that help things well I
think that in some ways comedians are
much more rare and so I just did a a big
tour of the United States and you live
there so so it's like the water in which
you swim but my feeling is that every
single person that I met on the street
is like oh you should be on TV every
American I met was like you how do you
not have your own show it's crazy I went
to Detroit Chicago um St Louis Memphis
and New Orleans and I would say nine of
the 10 people I met I was like this
person is like
a 100 times so funny can I tell you I
met somebody not this trip but another
trip in a different part of Canada and
they were like the most flat person I
had ever met and Country they proceeded
to tell me about their TV show idea and
that and I was like who who would be in
it and they were like me and I was like
I mean I had to bite my tongue that but
in a loving way I almost wanted and then
I was like and then they were like or
you know somebody else and I was like
you don't even care if it's you and like
it was the most benign pitch so if I'm
hearing you correctly the states doesn't
have that issue like not at all and in
Canada if you get if you start doing any
in terms of perform like all the Second
City guys in the 80s who who exploded
like you stand out you stand out in a
big way and I think that while that may
seem crippling because the numbers are
lower like there's less people who are
trying to be class clowns which in my
opinion is like the first kind of step
on the stair case towards being a in
comedy you you wind up getting all the
resources and by that I mean all the
attention yeah right because it's not
you're not going to an entire High
School of people who all want to be
famous that's very rare in this
country so you know so so John Candy and
Eugene Levy like those are like the few
guys in their schools they got it all oh
that's the funny guy that's the one guy
who's funny and he's gonna be on TV one
day just because our culture is so
you're a weird farm league in that way
like you get like for for the United
States in fact I got a huge political
problem with that believe it or not I'm
trying to I'm trying to stop that in my
career the kind of brain drain
specifically filmers and actors to the
United States because it you know what
you may you wouldn't realize it at all
but because you're surrounded by it in
Los Angeles or New York or even Chicago
in Toronto there's no Role Models
everybody leaves and so what are we left
with right like there's nobody that
young people can look to and be like oh
I want to be like them in fact they they
they they hear oh my God I didn't know
Jim krey was Canadian oh wow I didn't
know John Cy was Canadian like you don't
you don't even realize these guys are
from this country when you're growing up
here until you get to a certain age and
so because they're not here and
everybody leaves because that's the only
marker of success we don't have a it's
it's it's not fertile ground to develop
an industry like there is no Canadian
film industry at all and you want to fix
that deeply I badly want to fix it I I
what I I I want to try to find ways to
make it so that young people stop making
the the marker of
success transplanting themselves to
another country yeah i' I'd love it if
if young people could be like oh I
really want to make movies in Toronto I
really want to make movies in Winnipeg I
really want to make movies in Vancouver
because we don't have a national voice
it's not like the like Blackberry is
probably the first Canadian movie you've
seen in your life would be my would be
my
guess and and it's that way for most
people I've seen some of Jay's horror
movies okay never mind never mind then
okay okay but yes yeah no but you're
right I that's a very fair point
pardon the interruption weirdos this
episode is brought To Us by our friends
at Roosevelt's RS lvts look I changed
I'm traveling I'm currently in Winnipeg
Canada shooting a movie I only brought
one dress shirt and of course it is a
Roosevelts Roosevelts are the makers of
my favorite feeling fitting and looking
clothing and apparel that I have
discovered in recent years they are
incredible and they're also very very
fun it's called Roosevelts
rsvlts it's an apparel brand born for
their passion for pop culture and
Americana they combine highquality
products with fun bold designs to offer
a uniquely rad concept their team has a
little bit of something for everyone
with uh Star Wars stuff Disney
Nickelodeon to classic movies and shows
like the big Labowski the office and
tons more this is the best way to get a
gift for The Fanatic in your life
somebody that loves any of these franch
ches or if your style is a little bit
more laidback like mine they just have
classic prints that look awesome I've
worn them on lat night TV I've worn them
to movie premieres high quality threads
that look fun and help you pop just a
little bit not too much not too much but
just a little bit get a conversation
going have a little bit more fun light
stretchy soft and fit so damn nice
they're moisture wicking extremely
breathable made from kunu Flex which is
a four-way stretch material so it almost
has like an athletic feel but looks
dressed up but also kind of casual have
shirts for everyone they have toddlers
youth men and women like I said Jurassic
Park the office and even more laidback
like this Boke bespoke original designs
they won't shrink a wrinkle after
washing in fact that's one of the
reasons I love traveling with them and
wearing them on stage I throw them in my
carry-on I take them out they are ready
to wear based out of Hoboken New Jersey
clothing for for The Bold and the fun
those who dare Mighty things just like
their Nam sake Teddy Roosevelt once said
if you get your hands on some of these
amazing items visit roosevelt. comom
that's
rsvlts dcom or check them out on
Instagram at
rsvlts they're awesome absolutely get
into it also brought To Us by our
friends at electric ebikes I don't know
if you guys have known this we got
electric ebike about a year ago and it's
absolutely changed our lives we decked
it out I got the support seat uh which
installed very very easily and I cruise
around with Leela on the back it's made
going for errands so much more fun so
much more enjoyable we hop over or ride
over to the grocery store ride back so
easily easy to add storage easy to
cruise that's what I love most about it
it's so fun it's so intuitive it's fast
but not like insane it's it's certainly
not a motorcycle it's comfortable is
what I'm saying I got on it a little bit
shaky at first I was like is this going
to be okay couldn't have been easier
just a little turn of the throttle or
the pedal assist gets you moving gets
you outside gets you exercising uh Leela
and I now go for epic long daddy
daughter bike rides end up somewhere get
some pizza and ride back the battery on
the one that I have which is called the
expedition lasts so long it is
incredible any can anyone can ride
designed for a better mode of
transportation for all Riders durable
features and accessories for added
safety convenience and control save on
gas parking and maintenance that's one
of the things I love we go to the
farmers market once a week always the
parking lot is full take the ebike
absolutely no problem same safety
regulations and Road access as regular
bikes in Most states licenses
registration and inspection are not
required but always check the laws in
your area we absolutely love it add more
physical activity get more out outside
time to your everyday life up to 150 M
on one charge with Electric's unbeatable
long range options so explore 2024 with
electric ebikes the most accessible and
adventurous ebikes ever visit electric
bikes.com to learn more and be sure to
mention you made it weird with Pete
Holmes sent you in on the post checkout
survey support the show support your
life that's l c r i c bikes.com and do
fill out that survey and tell them that
you made it weird sent you all right
everybody back to Matt
Johnson um so they there's no voice you
make it I had something I was gonna say
there are other things I could say but
you had me on something good I guess
there's something to be said about
like oh that's what it was the joke in
La I live outside of LA
is like move to LA to make movies and
shoot them in Montreal Vancouver and
Winnipeg yeah right but like there's
this bizarre I like La I don't I don't
even live there anymore but like there
is a sacrifice to living in these are
the bad things about La vapid sort of
self-obsessed very uh
external all the all the stereotypes um
are are valid to a certain extent so you
move there and you're in this weird town
that only does one thing really I know
there are other things happening but
there's obsession with show business but
then you end up shooting in Canada
everything everything she I've been to
Canada six times in the past I don't
know 18 months and that that's crazy
that's absurd everything shoots in
Canada everything every once in a while
you'll do something and they're like it
shoots in LA and you're like you're like
my God I can drive like it's it's an
absurd thing so it stands to reason that
you could just I mean it already exists
the infrastructure already exists well
can I tell you the dark brother of this
story that you're telling me which is
gonna make you go oh my God I can't
believe it so there's so much American
production that goes on in my country
specifically in Toronto that Canadian
filmmakers like well like me for example
making Blackberry all the studios are
booked all the crews are booked all
Canadian film has to shoot outside of
Toronto because we can't afford to shoot
in the city because it's all full of
American production so the whole reason
that we shot Blackberry way outside like
when Glenn came to Toronto he was like I
love Toronto I got lots of friends here
and I didn't have the heart to tell him
well look you're gonna be about an hour
and a half from Toronto because we can't
actually afford to be there because no
Canadian filmmakers can shoot in the
city all shooting way outside it's we're
like go ahead it's just we're relegated
to to a second status within within our
country just because yeah yeah right
literally I I'm worried though because
of the money thing it does seem like
just such a you know David and Goliath
thing of course of course and I and I
don't begrudge it in fact like I I kind
of only tongue and cheek sales is a big
problem because I'll Bloomer I'm planted
and that's the advice I give all young
people but it is a kind of irony that
the only Productions that can afford to
shoot in Canada are American Productions
that come in and use our cities as
though they're New York or Los Angeles
or
Chicago okay let me ask you some
specific uh Nirvana the band the show
questions I I was curious what you buy
speed yes yeah and they're just that's a
real that's a real drug deal it's a real
drug deal yeah yeah it's a very you just
you would the joke is that you're just
going up to people and saying do you
have any speed and you do not a joke I
need
speed I need speed you don't really need
speed you're pretending to need speed
yes right but you know how close are
they because I really do need somebody
to actually sell me the speed so I true
so I can't I can't [__] them I can't
walk up as though I'm in Candid Camera
no I I went to I went to drug Corner in
uh in Toronto which is actually a very
safe place and uh and I knew we got
lucky in that there was that Street
Preacher there on the day trying to
invite drug addicts in to try to clean
them and so I got to have that
incredibly um two-toned conversation
with him where I'm telling him with a
straight face no no the speed's not for
me I need it for a friend to win a gold
KN tournament we really need the speed
and he's looking at me like oh this
guy's so far gone yeah oh he's lying
even to
me that so you find o a woman it seems
she's blurred and she just so sold you
speed just like that she connected she
she connected me with somebody who had
the Speed yeah
oh and you bought $200 worth of speed I
gave her the $200 she gave me the speed
and in the end I was like you know what
I don't actually need this because I
knew we weren't going to do the speed on
camera so then we're using like dummy
drugs in the rest of the episode but I
wanted the deal to be legitimate you
know so you gave her the speed as a as a
gratuity well it was hers to begin with
so I just gave it back yeah
yeah has a hidden camera thing ever gone
so wrong that you didn't use
it well it depends what you mean by so
wrong the worst thing that ever happened
was in season one we spent about a week
building an exhibit inside the biggest
Museum in Canada because we wanted to
smash it and break it out and run and
that went perfectly but there was an
undercover police officer in the museum
right there when we did it and so I
smashed this huge glass fake glass um
exhibit to steal a map and then Jay and
I try to leave calmly um and this guy
grabbed me and was like don't move
you're under arrest and I realized okay
if I don't because we need to get out of
there for the plot to keep going and so
I was like okay Jay we have to run and
so I say Jay run I'm on camera telling
character and I kind of spin out of this
guy's grasp and we ran for our lives and
they chased us right onto the subway
which is the clip that you saw where we
then jump on the tracks to get away so
what you didn't see right before that is
we escape from him and then the security
guards chasing us out of this Museum and
later we went back and we're like hey we
didn't steal anything we had built that
in your Museum without you knowing it
over the course of a week but that was
as bad as it got and and and that was
pretty incredible that happed oh go
ahead I I it was it was one of the most
intricate things that we did because we
wanted to do something real where the
where the public and and the people
there would react like oh my God they're
robbing a museum but again because we're
Canadian like we don't want to actually
do anything bad like we don't want to
actually get put anybody uh out so so
our art uh production designer Adam
Balan just went in secretly building
this exhibit over the course of days oh
my God that is incredible that happened
in the movie um once have you seen once
no but I but I my producer loves this
film well you know one of the things I
think you'll like about it as a
filmmaker is they shot it in public
um with very long lenses so no one knew
and there's a couple funny things about
that one is that Glenn Glenn hanser
who's in it is famous so every once in a
while PE you can see people noticing him
like which is not right for the movie
and then they do a scene towards the
beginning where someone steals his bag
like his guitar bag which is filled with
money they pick it up and run but
they're shooting with long lenses so
someone in one of the takes chased the
guy and tackled him so the actor got
tackled exactly what happened to you so
there are these use it I don't think
they use the take where the guy got
chased because it sort of ruined it sort
of ruined everything see I always I
always try to put myself in a position
where when something goes wrong we use
it like you got because then people are
like what the hell how they do it it's
like the rule if the scent guy dies you
have to use use the take which is yeah
yeah which is something I I I
desperately live by I don't want to kill
the patient on the operating table
because there is this magic to the show
and I I can't say enough good things
about it to to watch
something that even as a as a Creator as
a comedian kept me guessing and I was
always surprised by the plot I'm
covering my face I'm shocked I'm feeling
all these things you know what I mean
when you watch something and you go like
it can still be done it can still it can
still happen it's my it's my favorite
feeling it's I call it I call it the
metav viewing experience where you're
watching it here but you're also
watching it here I this is like the most
addictive it's like when you're watching
a m magician perform a trick where
you're watching the story of the trick
while simultaneously unpacking how is
this trick happening yes it's an amazing
feeling that I feel like only Cinema and
Magic can do only those two
art no no not at all I I I I I know
little about it but but but I know that
experience I'm a big Orson Wells fan and
Orson Wells was a a notorious magician
and and so
that was my way in but I love this
feeling I know exactly what you're
talking about you're right in when I
started I'm not a magician but I love
magic just because I like to know how
things work but I don't do it to ruin it
I do it I do it to appreciate it so when
David bla special came out his first one
the street magic one I learned all the
tricks I still know them they're great
tricks but it wasn't to go like [__] you
you're not magic it was because I was
like no to appreciate it it was to
appreciate it I was like I can't and
that's how I feel when you're crawling
under the table during the golden ey
thing and when when he's dying on the
floor and then so I don't want to ruin
it so it's from the spirit of
appreciation when you're going into the
hockey game and you want to get on the
kiss cam yes I'm like okay you know
metav viewing I'm going like yeah that
stands to reason if these guys so I'm
trying to be ahead of the story casually
these guys are going to do they're going
to act so crazy if I want
they'll get on the cam and I'm like they
want to get on the camera and then this
by the way I could tell you every beat
of the story it wouldn't ruin the
episode for you your plot is to get on
the camera and then you'll kiss you and
your your male friend and you'll expose
the homophobia and everyone will puke
and then at the game the kiss cam goes
on two
men before you guys yeah they kiss and
everybody's obviously totally cool with
it cheering yeah they're cheering it's
actually very sweet uh I say actually
because it's it's not often that you see
real warmth on a kiss cam but there's
like affection and love coming
through but then it cuts to you guys and
it's brilliant I won't say what you do
it ends up being unbelievably hilarious
but I do want to know magician to
magician why did they cut to you guys
they didn't they didn't cut to us no we
we shut that all it's we shot that in
three pieces we shot us at the game we
shot us in a different um stadium and
then we shot that entire kiss cam was
all done with VFX there is no kiss cam
at games so all of these things although
it's happening real and you really see
me throw up like all these things are
real they're happening in completely
different realities and then combined
into one so that you think that what
you're seeing is is happening it's
Spielberg in the desert with his mom
with the 8 millimeter like it's it's
what I'm it's a really high compliment I
think I'm giving you is like there's
just so much effort and Imagination and
we're going back to what we were saying
at the top of our chat is like a
childlike and this is what's missing so
much is what could we do it's life it's
like white lightening and it's usually
for children and if grown-ups can get
that sort of but what could we do and
then and the answer is anything yeah and
like I just watching your show and
talking to you now is and I hope for the
listeners is really just
reanimating this pure childlike not
childish but
childlike wait I know you remember me
and my friends with our cam quarters
when I was in junior high my
camcorder would' just be like we could
do any and would just do it and when I
look back it it was the funniest thing
in the world it was the funniest thing
in the world I looked back on those
ideas I was just think about one two
days ago me and my friend Aaron I called
him ER I still call him ER was The
Adventures of George and George just two
guys that had the same name and I'm like
hilarious that's still funny it's still
funny to me that they're both Nam
because that could happen what's that
and the show makes that the CER piece
the fact that in the title it's the
adventures of George and George because
even the show knows that that's show
knows it's a joke which of course we
learned from The Simpsons and we learned
from other things but like and then we
had another one called spoon boy which
was the joke was he wasn't magical but
his spoon was magical so he couldn't fly
the spoon could fly could right he hold
on the keeper yeah yeah he was the spoon
keeper yeah I stand by that that was
plan it like well the one of the great
ironies is that the things that you did
when you're young and you're like oh my
God it's the best idea ever you just
can't ever let go of and it's so
impossible to contextually put the
people that you're explaining it to in
the heads space that you were in when it
was happening and yet it still has this
kind of magic to you I've been making
Nirvana the band the show since I was 20
years old and there's something about it
that I can't quite Shake I don't even
know how to explain it but there's just
something that is like if you get it you
get it and it is that return to the way
a child sees the world which is that
anything is possible and any day I could
wake up and write an idea on the
Whiteboard and that'll be the thing that
gets us to show at the rivy which is
exactly the way a young kid thinks which
is that I'm gonna be an adult any day
now yeah and I just need to do the right
thing and then bang but it's following
I'm gonna be an adult it's following
just enough of the rules meaning you
know you type in Nirvana the band the
show into Apple TV it shows you Flight
of the Concords I don't know if you know
that I'm not surprised at all because
that's how the algorithm works it's like
well you want to show about two guys
trying to make it so I think this is an
important step I'd love to hear you talk
about is like it's not just [__]
there's sorry to quote myself but there
was a a joke that makes me laugh in my
own Batman video where Aquaman says I'm
from Atlantis and I go why not Narnia as
long as we're doing [__] stuff
kills me so [__] stuff is like just
absolute nonsense but you're going like
what is the tell me if I'm right the
bare minimum of Storytelling structure
meaning these guys do have to have a
drive there needs to be something
otherwise we're not gonna we're not GNA
want to get on the train or watch them
if it was just them going like how can
we be idiots today yeah let's just
strictly be funny like what's the low
adaptive peak of us being ridiculous for
an audience look that's that's you're
describing the difference between me
when I was young versus me now which is
that I've learned that there structure
do do do you do much writing do you like
like I mean like like uh like screenplay
or anything like writing where it's like
he got it well you know standup comedy
is just like this there's something that
I learned about eight years ago that
completely changed my life about story
structure because when I was a kid I was
like like structure and rules of
storytelling are such [__] they're
just another imposed like don't shoot
movies with kids rule that I'm going to
do the opposite and I'm going to f I'm
going to use that as a map right I I I I
I swallowed my own poison and convinced
myself I was smarter than everything and
and I kept failing viciously viciously
failing uh at everything that I did that
involved long form storytelling until I
realized that to be against
structure as a Storyteller is like being
against a piano as a piano player it's
such an absurd thing to think it's like
you say you're a musican well what
instrument do you play it's like well I
don't play any instrument like structure
is the instrument that story is played
on it you you can't you can't you can't
you can't get rid of it you can't say
that you're not you're not going to deal
with structure because that is what a
story is a story is a structure and all
you do is play it you just play it
differently than other people play it
but you're still playing the structure
and and whenever I'd be writing things
with my friends we'd always notice that
it feels like when you're coming up with
an idea it feels like you're all
remembering the same dream that you had
the night before and so it's like you
you you have an idea it's like oh Matt
and Shay they have a hamburger and and
they take a bite and it grants wishes
somebody's like Ah that's ridiculous
it's like okay but maybe it's like he he
only finds the hamburgers because he got
thrown out of something and then
everybody starts being like oh yeah that
did happen in the dream oh yes that is
what's in the dream and then you all
reconcile the fact that you've had the
same dream yes the night before and it's
all the same but you just needed to
collectively remember it and that's what
fits it into this bizarre structure and
it's an insane feeling because you're
like how do we all know this yeah how do
we all know it and it gets us back to
this buor quote which is that we know it
because it is connected to some myth
that we can't name that existed before
us
that's why it all feels like we're
remembering the same dream because we
don't realize how closely myths and old
stories interact with our day-to-day
life and animate everything yes
brilliant absolutely brilliant well you
know the Joseph Campbell quote where he
goes myths are the collective dream like
myths I I don't know that specific one
but but absolutely I I just butchered it
but it's like it's like we're all having
the same dream and that's what a that's
what a myth is that's why
these stories resonate but what I love I
love every I just want to frame
everything you just said it's just
absolutely right be a huge frame it
would be rambling non rambling nonsense
in a huge frame I'd still frame it
because it's like when I'm writing alone
when I'm writing a
script I guess one of our jobs is to
keep your antenna clean you know what I
mean is like meaning your gut like
that's that's right and for some reason
that's wrong and I've said this a
million times but like when I was
working with J appau I just noticed that
like he had such it his his genius often
came down to exactly what you're saying
we're like the example I give this a
million times but I go there was an
episode of crashing Pete's Conservative
Christian parents come to see him do
stand up and everyone's filthy and then
Pete goes up and then Pete's parents are
proud of him him I wanted it to be this
little win for my character and then Jud
said or maybe uh they didn't like the
swearing but at least those people had a
perspective at least those people had
something to say yeah you're just kills
you yeah oh
oh like even in that example my ego is
getting in the way where I'm like no
what I was doing was better than those
people and he's like no those people
been doing stand for 10 years it would
be so much more interesting so when I'm
writing now I've sort of installed the
Jud software as sort of like a wizard or
like an oracle type voice that goes like
no in the dream it goes this way because
dreams and entertainment should be
surprising you know like they should be
surprising but inevitable yes that's the
real secret they need to be surprising
but inevitable like it needs to be like
of course that's what happened and I'm
and I can't believe it like that's the
real magic feeling yeah that surprising
but inevitable that's what I'll frame
because you know when you're doing
it you know I don't want to put any
movie down but like there's there's just
so much [__] that's just doing it
you know why they're doing it because
that's what other movies did sometimes
the source material of that movie was
another movie and the source material of
that movie was another movie and I know
it's a ruminant it's it's almost like a
cow constantly swallowing and then up
bringing up the same food over and over
it's Human Centipede yeah right right
right right even worse that's a much
more revolting
example I'm glad I went I try to use a
ruminant Bine and yeah you're talking
about humans being swed to one
another that's a very Canadian American
exchange yeah what is that line I keep I
think it was in um Kids in the Hall they
go I'm Canadian which means I'm like an
American without a gun yeah you're
you're giving me a um a Kids in the Hall
energy actually I can tell that you you
must have Lov that show I loved it too I
grew up on it I grew up on it that was
one of those shows that thank God it was
on MTV because I'm watching it and I'm
just like what the what the what is
happening what the [__] is this I know
it was Art comedy yeah where's my pen
and and like and the and the the
homosexual kind of commentary at a time
when like I was actively being called
gay as an insult almost daily and then
there's a show that's coming at it from
this completely now it seems so obvious
you know but H it I mean the debt we owe
your country now I pointed you that's
one of the few that stayed Canadian one
of the few shows that stayed Canadian
they never moved yeah they made it oh
stayed in Canada I thought you just
meant tone
no I I think I I think you're you're I I
I just I can't get enough about that
surprising but inevitable thing because
you just don't want to do it for its own
sake like you don't want to I've seen
things where like and then the hero
explodes or something you know like
they're they're doing it just because
they want to subvert the expectation but
it also needs to be inevitable it can't
just be surprising well you can't get
away from the myth you can't get away
from whatever the source is even if you
don't know what it is and so again it's
very painful but yeah you got to follow
the dream and if somebody says that
really isn't in the dream if one person
says it that's okay but if everybody
says it then it's like oh yeah I'm I
like what you did my ego is taken over
and I think I'm smarter than the story
which again brings us back to Blackberry
it's like when the ego is as Ryan
holiday says it is the enemy it's this
thing that wants it just wants power and
money and it's very to be right yeah I
always go back to tolken it's like these
things we're not supposed to have it
we're not supposed to have
power ring yeah you're not supposed to
have it you're supposed to throw it in
the [__] volcano uh but we can't and
and then what ends up happening is you
watch people turn into to golems and you
I you just I don't know you make fun of
reality TV I tried to watch the wallberg
show and I found it existentially
disturbing oh really yeah I I really was
like because when I see people like Mark
wallberg you know what really made me
want to vomit and I I'm really just
saying this to hear your response to it
is he's like there's this scene where he
gives his son and you know my own
psychology is bleeding through in this
but he gives his son his son is
collecting a certain type of baseball
card or something and he gives him
something that you know he brought him
every card no kid should ever have this
yeah he just gives them the and the
kid's just going through like a a filing
Clerk and finding the card he wants and
in the same scene Mark Wahlberg is
talking about how he wishes he could be
home more but he's like but I can't I
gotta go do this movie you know I I'm
doing this movie and it cuts to him
doing the movie and he's on a motorcycle
and he has like a blade style sword in
his back I'm like what are you doing
what the [__] are you talking about
would you does that bring up anything
for you I'm just like here's something
I'm going to give you this summation
I've tried to do this as stand up it
never works I go I will never say to my
daughter everything I do is for you [__]
that [__] I I'm modeling to her the the
value and the joy of pursuing your dream
and fulfilling it but I'll never put the
burden on them or the LIE the [__]
on them that I'm like I wish I could be
home more I could have not done this
movie are you [__] nuts and I'm not
even bragging about having enough money
to pay the bills I'm just saying like
eat [__] [__] I can't stand that
stuff and it's horrible yeah go ahead
well I was goingon to say this is
bringing up two two great ideas that
that uh that are are surrounding the
same world the first one is you know you
think that what that's doing is putting
a burden on your kid in many ways what
they're doing is sanitizing their own
reputation I am such a good dad because
of this I am such a good person because
of this but it reminds me of this great
quote about Steve Jobs his daughter said
um on his deathbed what Steve was saying
to her was oh I wish I had more time I
wish I had more time to spend with you
right and her response to that was you
just would have
worked you just would have worked and of
course isn't this just the truth that at
the end of our Lives we all want more
time to do the things that we wish we
had done and this is such an absurd
fantasy it makes absolutely no sense all
you have is time and you choosing how
you use it now is what's important and
so you you watch this kind you just
would have worked the you just would
have worked that's like a gangster movie
or something is it crazy it's an
unbelievable quote and between these two
figures who are so powerful right Steve
Jobs on his deathbed I wish I had more
time to spend with
you I know you you just would have
worked like your what he's talking about
his time in a mirror universe or a
pocket Universe where there's no apple
where I have no responsib but you can't
escape
yourself
dude I have everything to say but please
keep going you will I I I you you said
that this was you um self- pathologizing
yourself in a way and uh well you see
what I'm adverse to like I'll die before
that become I'll have another problem
but it won't be that well because you
don't want I I see this with people who
are not in Show Business a lot of
fathers one in particular that I'm
thinking of where there is a kind
of I'm doing all this my identity is I
suffer so that my kids can have what
they want right and that that's almost a
cliche archetypal father and without
realizing oh what's really going on here
is you're behaving in a way where you
feel as though you're bulletproof to all
criticism for how you behaved as an
actual dad that's it that's exactly it
right were you there for your kid in the
way that they needed you to be or did
you sublimate all of that to I work hard
and because I work hard and I make those
sacrifices that's what I did but of
course you're not admitting oh my job's
my identity I I love going to work I
love getting out of the house I love not
having the responsibility of being at
home with these kids and isn't it great
that I can come home with a whole pack
of baseball cards with which cost me
essentially nothing that no other Dad
could afford but I can't afford because
I'm so lucky and that is going to almost
expunge the record of all the times I
missed a baseball game Etc another thing
that I was thinking of when you're when
you're when you're when you're talking
about this this kid who all of a sudden
is given so many sports cards that he
doesn't know what to do with what you
don't realize as a parent you're doing
is you're essentially destroying that
hobby for your kid it's like it's like
the it's like the smoke the whole pack
punishment for when you catch a kid
smoking you do not want especially a
young boy to give them access to
everything that they want because
they've destroyed their exploration
right it's like if you're playing
Pokemon it's like why don't you just
take my cartridge I've got all 150
Pokemon you can play with all them right
now well congratulations you just killed
Pokemon yeah for this kid I played uh
Borderlands with Steve Ag and Steve AG
was uh way higher level than me and I
thought it would be fun and now I'm
collecting all the guns that I was doing
all of this searching around for and I
and then I just stopped playing
Borderlands I was like this this [__]
sucks the whole point the whole point is
ruined every video game I've ever played
at my my favorite part of it is in like
the however you want to analogize this
but the level one to level 10 of it
where you're just getting the bare
minimum to get by and then all of a
sudden because I'm such a I'm like Mike
lazarius like Jay Bell's character in
the movie I'm such a power gamer such a
perfectionist I'm like no no I've got to
do this perfectly got to do this great
and then as soon as I figured out the
absolute best way to do something I'm
like I can't play this game anymore yeah
because I've explored it there's no I
can't get there's nothing there's no
there's no no fresh territory I know I
always start over I I just started over
uh Shadow of Mordor because I'm I have
all this downtime here and then it was
like I realized I I saw that game that
game seemed amazing it's you play a
ranger in that game right yeah yeah yeah
yeah that game I saw somebody playing it
it looked incredible it is incredible
and the part that's the best is they
drop you off and you know in Mordor and
you're weak as [__] you don't know what
you're doing and you keep getting killed
and that's the best part of the game at
a certain part you get so powerful and
so good that it kill you it's the same
as breath of the wild like the the best
part of breath of the wild is the first
10 hours and right when you're on the
plateau and then all of a sudden you're
out and you realize the world is so big
and you're like oh my God this game's
incredible and then you're like okay I'm
just going to find every Shrine and
become invincible yeah and you've
basically gamified yourself the uh yeah
yeah yeah exactly it's it's so sad it is
sad and and there's something about life
that it goes back to what we were saying
about people don't somebody my friend
James um James bashara who's a an
incredible CEO angel investor just
brilliant Tech guy he was like the level
of Consciousness meaning the the mindset
that brings you to success is I'm
paraphrasing is not the type of
Consciousness you need to enjoy it or to
even experience it the opposite yeah
exactly so and and we watch this over
and over and over people could even win
the lottery and they're like oh I'm
gonna stay in my neighborhood I'm gonna
pay off my house I'm gonna pay off my
friend's house they don't do any of that
they you're always gonna put yourself in
the hole so you can keep playing the
game or wanting something new it's a
real shame what else what also this what
also this brought to mind was I was like
in our old house in
La I was like I'm gonna get a a new
bathtub I was like I just I just want to
get a new bathtub we're gonna take out
this bathtub and put in like I'm a big
guy put in like a big [__] off tub it
wasn't a fancy house at all but I was
like I'm gonna have like a nice
Sanctuary bathtub and then a couple days
went by and I took a very small dose of
LSC uh
yeah not enough to trip but enough
to I I think micro doing LS is very
interesting because you can take a low
amount and it has a very nice
anti-anxiety kind of a a presence
presence it makes you more present makes
you a a little bit more uh open and I
ended up in my pants which is like an
LSD cliche I got in the tub in our
upstairs bathroom which I had never used
and I was having a great time it wasn't
a drug scene in a movie where I'm like
giggling and drooling it wasn't
embarrassing it's very it's just warm
water yeah yeah it was just sitting
there in warm water and it was
incredible I was really like like gilges
coming back I was yeah right exactly you
didn't realize the kingdom you had oh my
God hot water on demand what percentage
of the world am I in of humanity am I in
that and I wanted to do it in my pants
because I wanted to see what that would
feel like I wanted to see what a bath in
my pants would feel like and I had this
micro Epiphany which doesn't really you
I I needed the experience you couldn't
just tell me this I need to experience
it almost as like voice came to me that
was like you don't want a new bathtub
you want to be able to appreciate baths
you want to be able you want to have an
openness a spaciousness and a curiosity
yes and aliveness so Steve Jobs didn't
want time with his daughter he wanted
the ability to do the things that he
wished he could do and the problem is
the type of drive that it takes to find
to be the founder of Apple Cuts you off
from that destroy Jesus would say
getting Jesus here what good is it to
gain the whole world and to lose your
soul right soul
meaning soul is a fancy word for your
base spacious
Limitless awareness it's it's just
what's looking out your eyes or when you
close your eyes it's this field within
which everything appears but the
qualities of that awareness when we
explore it doesn't resist anything it
it's open and flowing and it's like
having a dream and realizing you're
dreaming if you've ever had a lucid
dream everything becomes so amazing and
if we can do that in our Waking Life
next thing you know with or without
drugs I've done it both ways next thing
you know you're taking a bath but you're
actually [__] taking a bath right
it's again to use this metaphor that we
CED about five times beginning this
conversation it's like being a kid again
yeah where everything is optimism
everything is happening for the first
time and you're you're at level three in
the game and you're like I have the
whole game ahead of me oh my God and you
and you have this feeling of I want to
get so good at this game only to realize
by the end you get so good that you're
like I don't want to play anymore but
that's why you have to be born again
which is is sort of the Christian
mythology but the other traditions would
say you have to die before you die you
have to like Drop it so ramdas would say
he's coming from the Buddhist Hindu
tradition you have to be somebody before
you can be nobody so that's kind of what
happens to Glenn's character is he
becomes somebody and then you can tear
it down so the irony is I can't say to
my daughter she's five so we're walking
around Winnipeg we made like a [__]
A+ 10 out of 10 classic family memory
and all we did was walk one city block
with a 5-year-old in the snow because
she does not have any concept of my feet
will be cold later I will be wet later
she's just like there's snow now yes now
she jumped in every pile and and we're
doing it too we're just doing it with a
little more resistance I'm making
snowballs and I'm like H my hands are
going to be cold and wet but we're
following her lead but here's what I was
going to say I can't stop her from
becoming somebody because that's you
have to become Gilgamesh and then leave
the kingdom and then come back to it
that's again and again and again and
again and again and again and again
that's death resurrection that that's
that yeah that's the revivifying pattern
of Life which so many people basically
abandon because they're so afraid to
leave their kingdom yes right they just
they just can't they just can't do it
again I mean I'm you're describing my
whole country here but yeah and but then
that's the the odd hidden Grace of
suffering so my wife left me this is my
famous little suffering story when I was
28 but what I didn't know was I was on
the course to that long gray line of The
Quiet life of desperation like that that
was and she saw it so she got out you
know she gave me this thing that I never
would have wanted never would have asked
for and then it disrupts you so like now
I I I I can lose sleep wondering like
what would have happened if I hadn't had
that what seemed like a tragedy so do
you see what I'm saying like we don't
want death we don't want death we don't
want death any type of death
psychological or otherwise and then when
we're confronted with it it can often
lead you to like Stephen pressfield I'm
all over the place because I'm all lit
up but Steph pressfield in the war of
art talks about people that get a
diagnosis and and they're very ill so
they decide like [__] it what am I doing
working at Dunder Mifflin Paper Company
I'm going to quit and I'm going to write
that thing that's been on my heart to
write like they know what their purpose
is and then he says I've heard it a
million times they quit they move to the
a little cabin and they write their
thing and then the disease goes away I
know it sounds like snake oil I'm not
saying that's a cure all but that there
does seem to be a yearning of this of
reality to express itself I forget who
said it um eternity is in love with the
creation of time it it wants to play my
daughter's name means the play of the
universe it wants to create and explore
and when you resist that and you're
blocked isn't it weird that that there
is a a force that like without getting
too woo that wants to play well look
that isn't that what they all the old
Greeks they used to call the four human
and if one was out that's what made you
sick it was like there used to be a very
close connection between your behavior
your dreams the things you did in your
life and your physical health all the
time but it's why these these archetypes
are so easy to spot you see some crooked
old man hunched over walking around so
like Scrooge like and you're like I
guess this this guy seems somewhat
unfulfilled it seems like he's he's
resentful and didn't get the things that
he wanted it's like we all manifest Our
Own Story whether we want to or not and
what happens to Scrooge is he's
disrupted by essentially death death
exactly ex and we have that with
near-death experiences we have that with
breakups we have that with losing jobs
and it is it does seem to be a huge part
of the cosmic joke is we say it all the
time on this podcast but what you want
is on the other side of what you don't
want Joseph Campbell said the thing you
want is in the cave you're afraid to go
exactly and in the filth in the filth it
will be found is what is that that's
that's the that's the um uh Latin term
of this of where Joseph Campbell got
that idea I don't know how to say it in
Latin but it's in the filth it will be
found wow that's the English translation
of it I've heard that that like the
Orchid grows in [__] and all that sort
of stuff it's like but but we
still we still avoid it because it's so
it's so much um well it's not in keeping
with our um Pleasant and
uh everybody now now it's almost like a
person of the Court you know everybody
has we have such decadent lives we eat
better food than kings and queens did
even 50 years ago like everything is
just we we're indulged to the point
where we don't even want everyone to
know pain so why I love exercise it's
one of the other things I discovered as
an adult is exercising to the point
where you're in in extreme pain as often
as possible just so you can get close to
that feeling of of Glenn does it too
which is one was great uh uh well one of
the things that makes him great what he
does is that he's he's not afraid of
pain well that it's funny that everyone
who listens to the podcast knows I'm
going to bring up cold exposure but I do
I do cold exposure you don't have to do
that in Canada but I take cold showers
and stuff and there's something really
mythically great meaning amazing feeling
it's a microcosm too of going like I
don't want this and you do it and your
body what is it it do it gives you all
these Feelgood chem it's it's what I'm
saying everything you want is on the
other side of something you don't want
and exercise is this like little
representation of that idea but that's
for everything like you sucking it
standup and propelling you you don't get
propelled harder into film if you didn't
suck at standup so you had to like
that's for sure that's for sure but you
know I could turn that on its head as
well and say oh wow maybe I was supposed
to be a stand-up comedian but was too
afraid to pass through this threshold of
humiliation and if only I had then God
knows what my life would have been you
know yeah that yeah when I was a kid I
was my big dream I saw that documentary
comedian I'm not sure if you ever saw it
one thousand one of my I'm telling you I
watched this movie so many times a kid I
know every line that ornie Adams says in
that thing like I was obsessed with that
movie and I thought I can do this and uh
boy boy that it ever destroy me but I
think you were obsessed with the that
that movie works again because it has a
Mythic thing going on it's a hero's
journey people have said that like um
Colin Quinn is like Han
Solo uh you know Jerry is like Skywalker
unfortunately Cosby I know is like Yoda
but there's is there I know yes uh that
even in a documentary which as you know
is is so painstakingly constructed is
following a pattern
that you were like dude I moved to New
York because I watched that movie I was
in ch I was in Chicago I watched it and
like within six months I had moved to
New York because I was like and if I I
wouldn't have phrased it this way now
but I was like okay there seems to be an
amount of [__] pain that I have to eat
and it seems like there's an all you can
eat buffet in New York h well Jerry says
it so well with that story about those
construction workers in the documentary
where he says he sees these construction
workers walking back after lunch and he
has this Epiphany after he's just been
[__] around not writing just kind of
twiddling his thumbs and he goes what am
I doing these guys don't want to go back
to work but they're doing it yeah why
can't I summon up even one tenth of the
dedication that these guys have to meet
to sitting in a room writing jokes this
really changed my life I still don't
live up to the work display neither not
even close two things I put a picture
that I printed from the internet of
construction workers by my bed because
of that quote really wow amazed that we
we've we stumbled on this common ground
to be honest I almost bought a um one of
those punch card clock in clock out
things for my desk which is a cute idea
but I'm glad I didn't do it that was
kind of dumb but I I wanted like a
record of how much time I had been at my
desk that was a little too type for me
but that had that much of an effect on
me I still try to do it now I've gotten
a little bit more lenient meaning I know
my process and I'm curious about yours
well enough to know that if I sit down
some days I set aside just to write and
I sit down and I can just tell it's a
hard no like the to go back to the muses
like the Greeks The Muse just isn't
there that day I know Stephen pressfield
would be like just shut up and [__]
do it anyway but I just will I'm very
lenient and I know three nights ago I
went to bed and I'm working on this idea
and I went to bed and it was so
inconvenient but ideas just kept waking
me up and I was like yeah I'm again
going back to the antenna I'm trying to
live with a clean enough antenna that
whenever it comes through that's when
I'll show up yeah yeah you don't dead it
yeah I would say we're s we're similar
in that way in that like if if it's
there I'm writing I I really struggle
with procrastination in a major way I'm
such a perfectionist and putting
anything on paper I'm just faced with
obviously it's death versus what I have
in my head and I really suffer with that
like in a major way but I spend a lot of
time alone up like I spend a lot of time
here and I spend a lot of
time very much like this conversation
now
inventing work through conversation and
and disguising my writing in pitching or
disguising my writing in just just
conversation between friends so I can't
tell you the number of pitch meetings
I've been in with strangers where I have
written the entire movie in the course
of pitching it to them and there was no
idea before the pitch began and this has
happened to me o over over 12 times and
it'll be done I'll be like oh yeah oh my
God you have no idea because you needed
the pressure see you are like a standup
you need the audience there to make it
audiences are everything to me audiences
are everything to me it makes a huge
huge difference so you would start
pitching talking out of your ass and at
the end of the with nothing yeah with
nothing with nothing yeah with nothing
did that
Blackberry 100
per. yeah 100 perc because we knew I had
been given the book didn't read it was
brought into pitch it like okay so what
are you going to do and I just started
talking and then these basic IDE is just
came out I knew who the characters were
and that's it but I'm telling you the
movie you're watching is that is that
the manifestation of that whatever I
said in that
room yeah but the thing is you know you
you you like it it happens you know it's
like it's like lightning strikes and
then you still got to build out around
it and that and that that takes a while
but uh
that's I again I've said this three
times I don't want to flatter myself but
I'm very similar in in fact a big
problem for me so the show I'm working
on right now very simple idea small idea
and I can tell I did I pitched it I
wasn't planning on pitching it to an
executive and I start talking about it
and as I'm talking about it I'm like oh
it's kind of coming together wait a
minute this is actually pretty good this
is pretty good great feeling yeah great
but then in the refinement talk about
losing the patient on the operating
table I'm like I don't want to ruin it
by saying too much about it because I I
kind of want to leave it this is a
series not a movie I want to leave it
Room to Grow that's also something Jed
taught me is he's like we don't know you
shoot the he's Jud so he gets to say
that but like you shoot the pilot me and
this guy have a great chemistry so now
he's a major character like that's
that's kind of how he did it right right
right right right right so I don't want
to like polish it to Perfection because
then they really know what the show is
and then they'll say no if they don't
like I dude you speaking this is what I
say all the time I'm I look there's
nothing worse I'm always saying whenever
we're going into pitch something or
talking about something he like we
better not work we better not know all
these answers because if we know them
then there's no room for the imagination
of the executives like they need to
think that this is going to be like the
best possible version of what it is and
as soon as you write it into a script
you're like no no this is exactly what
it's going to be this is exactly what
season one's going to be you leave like
leave a little space for the for the
Holy Ghost you know
leave a leave a little space God I love
this so sibler okay let's wrap this up
we've taken I hope I'm not helping you
procras procrastinate currently oh
certainly Yeah couple um couple easy
ones
certainly couple easy ones have you ever
seen a
ghost when I was a kid I didn't I didn't
see it but I was you'll never believe
this but I was at my computer I'm 15
years old old and I'm like oh I imagine
there's some creature just outside the
window you know I was just playing
little games with myself I imagine
there's some creature out there it was
like 2 in the morning and then all of a
sudden literally at my window sill I
hear the most like stigan Abyssal shriek
like the shriek and it was like was like
from like three feet from my head like
the shriek of in retrospect it must have
been a dying bird or something like that
but I I didn't I went right to bed I
just got in the bed and lay down and
went to sleep and it was after I had
thought oh I think there's something
spooky out the window but I would play
games with myself like that all the time
but it truly did happen exactly like
that this shriek this like I mean I
can't even reproduce it did you freak
out you yeah oh my God I couldn't
believe it I didn't scream but I was
like oh God and then I I I I got up and
just went into the bed I turned off
every Quest see tell me when you're
making movies just keep this in mind in
your unconscious you don't have to
remember it but like I remember I was
going to break up with a girlfriend that
I really cared for but it just wasn't I
could tell it wasn't right and I really
didn't want to break up with them and I
was getting in my car I was leaving my
friend's house where they had coached me
through it tell me if this doesn't sound
like something I'd pitched you for a
movie and you'd be like it's a little on
the nose it happened I got out of my
friend's house dark La Street walking in
my little rental car and I
heard I still don't know what it was but
it was like the sound of a dying
animal it might have been a coyote or
something but I had never heard all the
wonderful words you just heard used it
sounded like primordial and it was just
sort of like howling in pain clearly
dying something was dying and I just
stood there tell me if that's not you
know we crane up and we cut to Black
like because that's how I felt I felt
like I was watching a dying animal and I
had to put it out of its misery and then
I heard a dying animal that needed to be
put out of its misery I was like
life synchronicity syn synchronicity and
this is a dream like this this is a
dream like themes are here like
metaphors are here like it just became
so clear to me in that
moment yeah right exactly that we're
getting messages from the side uh and
then no I've never seen a ghost no ghost
UFO I keep looking up here in Canada it
seems like no no I'm I'm a disbeliever
in in in UFOs in a major way in a major
way even now yep even now even now I I
don't understand what do you think is
going on they keep coming out with this
footage yeah look I we're having the
opposite of a Joe Rogan Experience
right I I think that uh that people are
desperate to
find um but again I think this is so
connected PE people are desperate to try
to make sense of the world as it is and
there have always been creatures at the
border of a known territory back
thousands of years there's always
there's yeah there's always the
territory and there's the dog-faced
monster that lives in the land next door
there's always this thing just outside
the known that is coming to destroy us
that is evil that is what magical that
it's bringing Secrets this is never
going away and aliens are just the the
current skin of that unfortunately
unfortunately I wish that they were real
but they are just the manifestation of
human beings being like there is
something outside our borders when you
see a a Tic Tac flying and making a
right turn and all that that's a bug
that's a bug that's a bug and and be a
bug it's a bug and unfortunately the way
lenses work is they're making it seem
much closer than it is it's a bug with
light on it that is turning such a way
yeah um do you have any feelings we've
talked a lot about myth and and quoted
some interesting folks do you have any
feelings about life like a big story for
life what's going on here if it's
religious or God or spiritual you mean
in terms of like a like like like a
truly religious like a um it doesn't
have to be religious but is there a
story or a framework that you put like
what's going on here you know I I'm I'm
Adams and I know I'm me and you're Adams
and you know you're you conscious I
think that that whether like by by pure
accident we are the descendants
of like a species that only learned to
make sense of themselves through stories
and those stories became so unbelievably
powerful that we are who we are because
of the power of those stories because of
this singular story of oh I heard about
this guy who went out into the darkness
and he killed this thing that was
killing us and he came back with all of
this gold and I knew him and this guy
was crazy and and we should all try to
be like him I believe that that story is
like wound up in our DNA and that we
cannot get away from that and so any
manifestation of any religious thought
um or anything that has numinous meaning
like or when ever you feel connected to
whatever you believe God to be is your
reuniting with those Original Stories
whatever they may be and and there's
hundreds of them and and they're
cross-cultural it doesn't matter who you
are we could take people from any walks
of life and they would have that same
like we were in a dark place there was
an unknown territory and one person went
into it and they came back alive and now
we love that guy so so I think that we
are basically we are the descendants of
these people we're we're we're the kites
we are the canites and uh and we can't
uh we can't get away from that as much
as we try we can't we can't escape that
and it's why I'm also have a very dim
view of of AI and uh and cyborgs and and
and and the notion that one day we'll be
in The Matrix and robots will be fooling
us that they themselves like I I don't
think any any robot will ever pass that
touring test where we we believe that it
is a human and that makes me seem very
naive but you know you
can I I make films and when somebody's
bad when somebody's bad at acting it's
so obvious it's like they just don't
work and I've always said if aliens do
come to find us the one job that a human
being would be better at than than
anything else would be spotting other
human beings we are so good at it we're
all m
at understanding if something is human
or not and if aliens came to find us
we'd be amazing border guards at their
planets to not letting or letting in
human beings gu would be like that's not
a human what are you talking about get
lost you not to get close and I feel
like that's exactly what what uh what is
going to happen with with uh with these
AI cyborgs I think I think yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's very interesting so
even the idea that do you see the same
sort of Storytelling at play when Elon
musk will very casually say like this
will be our God like we're making like a
like a t Babel yeah it is Babylonian
isn't
it not I don't know I don't know enough
about it to be totally honest like I
don't I don't know what he was referring
to in that instance I uh yeah like I
have no idea but I I think that no
matter what we're always gonna have to
return to these basic
stories we have no choice we have no
choice it's it's interesting too like
with AI you know the SAG strike had all
that AI stuff they're going to AI Brad
Pit into movies after he's dead and all
that sort of stuff it is interesting to
consider that like a cut scene in a
video game like there just will be
something sort of off about it it
there'll be uncanny valley everywhere
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah the other
the other thing that the other thing
that you brought up I agree with you
that metaphor is the only way to talk
about without God for lack of a better
word but do you think there's something
that they're pointing to or is it just
straight materialism you know I'm not a
materialist no I I I I used to be in in
in a major way and I used to be like
like actually I'm pretty utilitarian but
like thinking that that's all there is
and and and life is kind of a cosmic
joke I don't believe that that's true
but but
that's like I am not mature enough for
sophisticated enough yet to unpack that
I know that getting back to that idea of
lying and me realizing
oh no matter what I shouldn't lie like I
even if I get away with it I don't get
away with it it's like there is a way of
being that is ideal that I should be
striving towards and that speaks to some
kind of you know like
a like a like a like an well to use that
same word like a kind of ideal that I
can't I can't I can't quantify I can't I
can't uh like I can't
explain um
but and yeah who knows like the idea
that this just happened by pure luck you
know there's an idea in in uh another
evolutionary biology idea that
like the very fact that something
exists is itself like you can define an
environment just by finding an
organism I'll give you a good one um
that our planet is this I think
something that Elon Musk is probably
interested in our planet is the exact
size to allow space travel off of it if
our planet was much bigger the gravity
would be so strong that no amount of
fuel that you could create from the
periodic table would allow you to send a
jet into space so in some ways it's
almost
like we must be destined to leave this
planet W simply because it is the size
that allows rocket propulsion to leave
right and if we were bigger it couldn't
we just couldn't and as something about
it being smaller also it couldn't work
again I'm total I know nothing about
this yeah but it's it's
like we are trying to find meaning in in
the fact that we exist but we exist and
therefore we must be in an environment
that has allowed us to be this way look
I
see at a certain level I'm like this is
not my job I don't I'm trying to stay
ignorant of these things um so that I
can uh not I can ignore them same with
politics but uh but I my my perspective
on these things changes the older I get
and I realize oh it seem things seem to
be connected in a way that I didn't
appreciate when I was younger H I love
that I'm you've said so many things I'm
never going to forget uh I can't promise
way remember I can't promise that I
can't promise that um dude I loved every
single part of this there's one last
question uh can you tell me a time in
your life it doesn't have to be a great
story where you laughed so hard you
thought you were going to puke or you
were crying just like a great laugh
moment of your life if one comes to
mind ye well I'm sure you know that when
you're working on things like this with
your friends you laugh all the time and
so yes a time that I laughed so much
that I thought I was going to
puke not even puke it could be when you
were a kid the prompts I usually give to
help and remember it doesn't have to be
an amazing story like you open the door
and there's John dvol it's just like
somebody fell somebody farted you know
what I'm saying it's like you were in
church you were in a place you weren't
supposed to
laugh uh yeah sure I'll tell you one and
it was me personally just laughing on my
own and I couldn't believe what was
happening and said I had a great friend
Nam named Ben Taylor who was loved food
but he was completely broke he was a
master student and he loved going to
fancy restaurants he always come to
Toronto um because he was doing his PhD
and some cardiovascular something rather
and he'd always want to go to these
super fancy dinners super fancy and I
would always pay for them because he had
no money but and I didn't know anything
about food so it's like that's kind of
what we're giving one another he'd pick
these restaurants and I'd pay for the
bill okay anyway we did this about a
dozen times and i' spent so much and I'm
broke right like I'm I'm just a like a
jobbing filmmaker and so I don't have
money but he is fully willing to have me
pay for these extravagant meals for
himself and we never really talked about
it it's just one of those things that I
fell into a trap of gratitude of sorry
of uh of generosity yeah so he gets a
job at McKenzie with his PhD and becomes
insanely wealthy insanely wealthy
and he comes back to Toronto he's like
Maddie I haven't seen you forever we're
gonna go to we're GNA go to one of these
dinners and I'm like that sounds great
you picked the spot I'll meet you there
so we go to one of these places it's
insanely expensive as always and the
bill comes and out of just kind of you
know politeness I reach for it and the
waiter's there and Benny goes no Maddie
come on you've taken me out to dinner so
many times I finally got money we're not
doing that anymore and he takes the bill
and he looks at the waiter and goes
we'll split
it and I just died I couldn't believe I
couldn't believe it like I thought this
is so so funny um and uh yeah yeah
surprising but inevitable but inevitable
yes surprising but inevitable and uh I
was watching it happening right before
me and he wasn't joking right it was a
sincere no way no way but that's what
made that's what made it so funny he's
my dear friend in fact he's the reason I
became a filmmaker is that he had made a
video for French class in grade seven
that I saw with him and his older
brother on VHS and I didn't know people
could do this and I watch this in class
and I was like insanely jealous
obviously it was so funny everybody's
laughing and hysterics I was pissing my
pants watching this video and I was like
this isn't fair I didn't know I didn't
know we were allowed to do this and that
what began my film making jealousy the
truest compliment the truest compliment
I love that so much we should end but
reminded me
in high school again me and er made they
gave us an assignment and they made the
mistake of saying it could be like a
poster board presentation it could be a
video and we were like oh my God and we
made a commercial for
dirt oh great still that's that's fine
it had to be about like some element or
something and of course it was just
nonsense and we're talking about how you
can make it into mud and so all the
different purposes of it yeah grow grow
vegetables what's better than dirt yeah
what a gift the80s were that camcs kind
of existed that you could do stuff like
that it changed my life same with me
cheap cheap in you Big C's home video
yes oh God buddy I I admire you so much
everybody go see blackberry and and and
watch Nirvana the band the show anything
else you'd like to plug no no not at all
Pete this was a total total pleasure I I
I can't believe where this conversation
uh took me I uh I know yeah and I'm I'm
like in a funk today that was what I was
gonna say to you as well is like I just
woke up today and I won't I'll SP you
the details but I was just sort of
like just didn't feel like myself and
then when I was watching your stuff and
I started laughing this is exactly what
you hope isn't it like I kind of started
to
remember myself and remember life and
laughing and and then talking to you lit
me up again I I was a little bit nervous
I was like I just don't feel like the
guy that has a podcast today but I
couldn't have been more excited to talk
to you and and it that completely
changed uh through this conversation so
thank you vice versa yeah thanks man
would you um God I'm so glad you said
that I'm just kidding would you say uh
keep it crispy which is how we end it's
just the sign off you say keep it crispy
y keep it crispy there it is there it is
keep it
crispy you made it win oh yeah you made
it win you made it win you made it win
oh yeah you made it you made it you made
it oh yeah you made it with you made it
with you made it with oh yeah sh